[Musique
] c'est le gril pour toi je l'ai appelé
l'Obama allez dis martèle mon elmo
le pitbull j'appelle ça la grosse
machine noire oh mon
dieu tu sens un peu le gaz est sorti
mais comment est le nerveux c'est juste un
rapide oh  tu es le meilleur vendeur que j'ai
jamais vu je peux te voir être
agent de change comme moi pourrais-tu me donner un
travail j'aimerais pouvoir mon patron ne me laissera pas
embaucher je laisserai tomber ce Mark Zuckerberg qu'il a
abandonné de Harvard  tu as abandonné le
lycée du Piémont qui était à quelques
crédits de l'obtention de mon diplôme Je dois obtenir
mon GED Je suis le directeur de cette école
Je peux faire ce que je veux
tu dirigeais ma
maison utilises-tu une voix noire non je n'entends pas
couleur d'accord faisons quelques
présentations mon nom est Carrie je suis ici
pour gagner un peu d'argent supplémentaire afin que je
puisse me permettre ce warnock que j'ai eu mais
ce n'est pas notre affaire
bienvenue à l'école du soir
ce livre est un peu épais je le
pensais '  d être plus comme un dépliant ça ne
va pas faire le travail laisser tomber la classe non je fais
le travail tu vas  voir nous verrons
oui nous allons super superbe excellent bien
tu vas être analyste financier
je suis et ça commence tout de suite
obtenez-vous du poulet du Seigneur
vous passez ce test attendrissez votre chemin
merci essayez-vous d'obtenir votre
GED essayez-vous d'obtenir votre GED oui vous
pouvez sortir de mon chemin [ __ ]
pas les soupçons étaient corrects oh tu es
cliniquement bas il n'y a pas  guérir pour
ce que tu as oh mon dieu je dois apprendre
et je dois donner aux gens donne-le garçon
tu as fait le truc des garçons noirs que nous avions ce n'est
pas une voix noire pas une voix noire tu
ne te souviens pas quand tu étais à cette
réunion il  était comme si nous allions l'
allumer ici cette réunion allumée c'était très
éclairé Je le garde 100 quand ne l'ai-je jamais
gardé 100
vous